SPEAKER 1: Welcome to
"Google Cloud Drawing
Board," where we drill
our way through the cloud.
Today's topic, "What is
High Performance Computing."
This video is divided
into chapters.
Watch the full
video or skip ahead
to any section of your choice.
High Performance
Computing, for HPC,
is an aggregation
of computing power
to solve problems
which are either too
large for standard computers
or would take too long.
It's also referred to as
supercomputing for this reason.
It enables the
simulation or analysis
of huge volumes of data
that would otherwise not
be possible with
standard computers.
The common challenge with
high performance computing
is that you're
producing or processing
more data than your
infrastructure resources can
handle, and you have to
wait for weeks or months
to see the results, which
typically delays the innovation
and slows down research.
You can think of a high
performance computing system
as a group of computers
called a cluster.
And each computer in a
cluster is called a node.
Each unit in the cluster
has an operating system,
a processor with
multiple cores, storage,
and networking
capabilities for the units
to talk to each other.
A smaller cluster,
for example, can
have 16 nodes with
64 cores, which
is four cores per
processor, helping you
solve the problem much faster.
A supercomputer is a much
larger variation of this.
An HPC job that would run
across an on-premises cluster
for three months could
run across 125,000 cores
in 16 hours in the cloud at
little or no incremental cost.
And by augmenting your HPC
environment with Google Cloud,
you gain economies
of scale with access
to the largest compute
and storage hardware,
global presence,
robust networking,
and intelligent automated
management capabilities
on the cleanest cloud.
Now, how to build HPC
environment on Google Cloud?
Compute, storage, and networking
are the building blocks
of high performance computing.
Compute Engine provides
customizable virtual machines
running in Google Cloud.
You can scale up
and down as needed
and choose from a
range of machine
types for your workloads.
We recommend the compute
optimized C2 machines for most
high performance
computing applications,
but you can also select
the general purpose
N1, N2, or N2D for applications
requiring larger memory sizes,
or A2 instances if
you need to use GPUs.
For very specific
requirements, you
can choose custom machine
types with the exact number
of cores and memory to match
your workload's requirements
and get the best
performance per dollar.
You could also use cost
effective preemptable VMs,
which are short-lived
compute instances
suitable for batch jobs and
fault-tolerant workloads.
Now, the underlying
storage system
is critical to the performance
of many HPC applications.
You have a lot of storage
options in Google Cloud.
Cloud storage is a highly
scalable object store
to store any amount of data.
Persistent disk is durable and
high performance block storage
for your VM instances.
Filestore high scale is a high
performance scale out system
that makes it easy to mount file
shares on Compute Engine VMs.
Networking, Google's
privately managed
global network
infrastructure ensures
that your data and applications
are the least exposed
to the public internet.
[INAUDIBLE] private
cloud VPC networks
are available to enable
connectivity from your Compute
Engine VM instances
and configure firewalls
for your applications.
With placement policies,
you can control
the placement of your
VMs in our data centers.
Compact placement policy
provides low latency
between nodes by placing
instances close together
within the same
network infrastructure
to speed communications
between nodes.
Now, let's put it all
together for your HPC workload
on Google Cloud.
First, determine
the compute storage
and networking requirements
for your HPC code,
then create your
HPC cluster using
Compute Engine
instances connected
to the storage of your choice.
Additionally, Google
Cloud supports several job
schedulers, making
it easy for you
to start autoscale
virtual machines
to meet job requirements or spin
down a cluster when a job is
complete, helping save cost.
Then visualize your
result in BigQuery or AI
Platform for post-processing.
From there, just
monitor the performance
and change the
cluster as needed.
Security is important
for any HPC workload.
Google Cloud's secure
by design infrastructure
protects your
data, applications,
and users with advanced
antimalware and threat
detection.
High performance computing
drives research, development,
and innovation in
many industries,
from rendering the visual
effects of the latest
blockbuster movie, to
sequencing the human genome
to cure diseases, to risk
analysis in financial services,
or even to design the
next generation of cars.
If this has piqued
your interest,
visit cloud.google.com/hpc to
learn more and get started.